[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
oh they're like trials or an interview
do me a favor can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man just
stay close to the ground you're the
spider-man from you two
can you summon anomaly of spiders oh
yeah no do you know him - miss - she'll
tell each other Sudan
the rich and the powerful like Stark
they don't care about us world's
changing boys time we changed too
these weapons are crazy dangerous
missing Peter forget the flying monster
guy there are people who handle the sort
of thing you legal weapons Barry was a
230 you missed it
what if somebody had died I was just
trying to be like you I want you to get
better I'm gonna need the suit back but
nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up you need
to stop carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand I'll do anything to protect
my family
I know you know what I'm talking about
don't mess with me cuz I'll kill you and
everybody you look
a guy he's still out there I've just got
to do this on my own
just don't do anything stupid
all right yeah
wait a minute you guys aren't the real
Avengers
I can tell Hulk gives it away